all right this is truly one of my
favorite fail clips from the last week
on the fox news show a fox and friends
steve ducey
who has never struck anybody as being
particularly with it let's be honest
about about ducey
he tried citing the number of coveted
deaths and people affected nationally
by the virus but what came out of his
mouth didn't make any sense and he sort
of seems to realize it now you may know
that in the united states more than 33
million people have
officially gotten the virus the real
number is probably more like 65 million
and more than 600 000 people officially
have died
and yet in this segment steve ducey says
here in the us 52 000 people have died
and 2 million people have been affected
by covid and as he says it
you see a sort of strange look on his
face and at one point he looks off
screen to his right almost as if
someone's flagging him
as if he realizes that what he's saying
makes no sense
but he just can't seem to get back on
track so check it out
think about it this way folks here in
the united states of america
52 000 americans have died from covet
52 000 i i was shocked to see that 33
000 of them actually lived here in new
york city which is
shocking uh 2 million americans have
been impacted so
how did it come to infect the entire
planet so this of course makes no sense
and what appears to have happened is
that ducey was trying to give the
coveted numbers
for new york state not for the united
states
which are close to the numbers he gave
in the state of new york
indeed 53 000 people have died of the
virus
about 2.1 million official cases
and later in the show ducey corrected
himself
he was apparently confused and he is
also a clown
the correction hilariously came during a
segment about
what else of course cancel culture
now a ton of people wrote to me saying
david this isn't a mistake
this was as usual trying to throw in a
low number
and then correcting so that it doesn't
look as though
trump failed as bad no i don't think so
i think this was just a mistake
i think ducey didn't realize that the
numbers he was giving made no sense
until he said it and then he sort of
realized it i don't believe that this is
nefarious i think it's the constant
confusion happening at fox news
and the constant confusion going on in
the brain of steve ducey
the only strange thing about the clip is
that no one
immediately said in his ear piece new
york not us new york not you not us
and that he could have immediately
corrected and said sorry that that's in
new york state not in the united states
that is weird i admit that
i don't have an explanation for that but
this is actually an opportunity to
remind you
the official numbers uh are nowhere near
the real estimated number of coveted
cases
and deaths and there's a lot of
different reasons for this first we can
talk about cases then we can talk about
deaths
one study suggests that cases which are
officially 33 million
could be two to three times that number
so
33 million official cases the real u.s
number
could be 66 million or 99 million why
a bunch of different reasons early on
before we even
knew about this virus as a separate
virus
from the flu there were tons of people
who had symptoms there were no tests
available at that point in time
or not enough tests they tested for flu
came back negative and just we're told
go home it's probably some virus that's
a whole bunch of people
in january 2020 february 2020 march even
into april i don't exactly remember was
it end of april early may when testing
really ramped up
so there's a whole bunch of people who
tested negative for the flu or never got
a test whatsoever
also a ton of asymptomatic cases now
the relevance of an asymptomatic case
you might say well we didn't capture in
the data a lot of those asymptomatic
cases
but they also don't really matter okay
that's a that's a debate but that's
another reason why the 33 million number
is very low people who had
an asymptomatic case or an almost
asymptomatic case
may never have thought to get tested uh
so real number of cases anywhere from
two to three times the official number
deaths one study suggests that the real
number of coveted deaths
could be not two to three times the
official number but could be thirty to
forty percent higher than the official
uh number one study says it could be 50
higher how could that be um a bunch of
different reasons
one there is a degree to which
sometimes someone dies and it's just not
being reported
locally as a cove of death number two
there are people who died in their homes
where they were never posthumously
tested for covid and they are
sort of what we would call presumed
cases but not necessarily
known cases so also a multiplier
if you take the official number of
coveted deaths if you want to get to the
real number
maybe you multiply by 1.3 1.4
maybe 1.5 so steve ducey yes
constant confusion going on there
whatever
but an opportunity to remind you that
even when we look at the official
numbers and we say
here's how bad it was and we make a
judgment about that
the real numbers are probably thirty to
fifty percent more deaths
and two to three times more cases one of
our sponsors
is vincero watches giving you fifteen
percent off
a high quality wristwatch is the perfect
way to
elevate your style own at least one
watch
that makes you feel great when you put
it on you can often see me wearing
my ventura watch on the show mine is the
gunmetal
vessel model i'm a big fan of the
metallic look
of the face of the watch i like the
silicone strap
you won't find a better made watch for
this good a price
anywhere else when you put it on you
know you got more than you paid for
vincero believes in crafting super
quality watches from high-end materials
but selling them at fair prices which is
why they have over twenty six
thousand five star reviews and they
stand behind
every watch they make with a one year
return policy and
five year warranty they'll give you
fifteen percent off everything in their
store
and free shipping at davidpakman.com
watch use the coupon code pacman